네 안녕하세요 저는 앞구정 로데오
아이입니다 강남에서도 제일 핫한
아니면 대한민국에서 가장 핫한 곳인데
제가 오늘은 앞구정 로데오를 좀
소개해 드리도록
[음악]
하겠습니다 시간이 오전 8시 30분
이어 가지고 사람이 없습니다 그래서
지금 날씨가 좀 많이 더워서 좀 른
아침에 좀 촬영이 나왔는데 요쪽 길
제가 봤을 때 제일 좋은 도로라고
생각하는 도로입니다 그래서 저쪽에
가면 원래 백권 맛 걸리 있었는데
그게 매각이 되면서 나갔어요 그래서
한 대지 평당 한 2억 3천만 원
정도의 매각이 됐습니다 지금 권박
걸리가 나가고 지금 임대를 마치려고
좀 준비 중인 거 같아요 그래서 이쪽
위치가 앞구정 로데오에서 좀 되게
좋은 위치라고 좀 생각을 하거든요
앞으로 좀 어떤 임차인이 들어올지 어
되게 기대가 됩니다 그래서 지금
최근에 팔린 매각사 앞으로 앞에
왔는데 지금 여기 주택이이 지금 얼마
정도 되는 주택 같으세요 최근에
[음악]
285억 팔렸습니다 그래서 대지 평당
한 2억 9천 약 2억 9천 정도
되고 여기에 용도 지역이 일종이에요
그래서 용적률이 이제 150% 밖에
받지 않은 땅인데 불구하고 2억
9천만 원에 어 매각이 됐습니다
그래서 여기 인근에 어떻게 보면
최고가를 경신했고 어 그리고 이제
종인데도 불구하고 그렇게 비싼 가격에
매각이
됐습니다 뭐야 왜 이렇게 많아
[음악]
아니 나만 두 개
샀어 거의 막한 개 이상씩 샀는데 저
보세요 지금
산더미처럼는데 지금 저는 이제 되게
소소하게 베이글 두 개랑 지금 거 했
원정도라고 아메리 부까지 해가지고
원래 구정 로데오가 되게 좀 많이
죽었어요 상권이 좀 많이 빠지면서
그게 이제 가로 스킬 쪽으로 넘어왔고
그러다가 이제 이쪽이 너무 죽으니까
건물주들이 이제 임대료를 되게 낮춰
줬어요 착한 임대인 해가지고 이제
임대료를 낮춰주면서 이런 뭐 핫한
업체들이 좀 이쪽으로 많이 들어왔어요
대표적으로 초기에는 이제
노티드 이제 그 한 오면 상이 다시
활성화되기 시작했고 그러면서 이제 좀
로데오가 좀 많이 살아났어 반면에
가로 스키는 좀 많이 지금 죽은
상태고 구정 로데오는 제가 봤을 때는
진짜 크게 뭔 이슈가 있지 않는
이상은 그래도 지금 상권에서 어 좀
더 더 상승 제가 베이글을 뉴욕에서도
먹어 봤는데 근데 한국 베이글이 더
맛있는 거 같아 물론 이제 한국인의
입맛에
맞춰서 어 만들긴 했지만 뉴욕에 있는
베이글을 제가 뭐 맛 넘는데 갔는지
모르겠지만 되게 좀 딱딱하고 짜 많이
자더라고요
한국 베이글은 그래도 제 입맛에 맞는
거 같습니다 아니 진짜 한국인 입맛에
딱 어 간도 딱 돼 있고 맛있는 거
같습니다네 그래서 오늘은 구종
로데오에 좀 와 봤습니다 지금 런던
베이글에 와 있는데 지금 여기 뭐 몇
분 안 앉아 있었는데 계속 계속 왔다
갔다 하는 거 같아요 포장도 되게
많고 그래서 어 이쪽 길이 진짜
얼마나 좀 활성화돼 있는지 체감할 수
있었습니다 그래서 오늘 좀 이렇게
간단하게 여기 근처 상권 분석이라 좀
했는데 어 여러분도
재밌으셨나요 어 다음 시간에 뵙도록
하겠습니다 감사합니다
[음악]